hello the Internet I'm CAF I'm down and
in this video I'm very keen to learn
what the hell is going on with a candle
when you light the smoke people are out
a candle and then tap a flame to the
smoke maybe like a couple of inches up
the candle just real light it's on its
own and I'm wondering if that's a fast
thing that we can't see or whether it's
just magic I think slow motion should
reveal something about that and we can
see how it works that way I've seen it
kind of go poof but I've never seen
anything travel down the smoke to the
flame I don't know so I want to see if
that happens
sure yeah Dan you'll be in charge of
flicking matches during the match
business phantoms rolling at
two-and-a-half thousand frames a second
focused up around there yeah Oh see it
see it to my eye there's nothing
happening there except the candle just
going food just lay up what I can do
those good wolf let's view the slow
so what I love about doing final guys is
that it's fun but also you can learn
stuff directly from the footage like I
just learned something from the footage
I just shot because you can literally
see the science yeah
happen so I love about these cameras
it's really cool isn't it I can't sit in
real time slow it down and it becomes
more obvious so explain what
scientifically what's happening there so
what's actually happening is the wax of
the candle is being burnt and vaporized
and what you're actually doing is
relighting the vapor trail of the
material the wax and it's tracing it
back down into the candle wick and
relighting it so the smoke that we saw
being real it is actually just vaporized
fuel for their candle yeah pretty much
it's just vaporized material which you
can then rely and it traces it back down
into a safe clean well I hope you
enjoyed that video maybe you learned
something I definitely did be sure to
follow us on Twitter by shirt yeah if
you want Dan you keep wearing that sure
how many of those shirts do you this is
like 12 in the you've got like 10 of
them do you keep taking about the prop
shake yeah they really yeah it's not
opening new shirt I wonder why the
volume of that bag was going down
looking fake it's all just going to the
[ __ ] Nikoli as always if Dan sees you
wearing a slow-mo guys shirt he will buy
you a drink
then and there even if there's no bar
he'll figure it out he'll go to a shop
with you and buy a beer similarly any
time the gap is wearing at roosterteeth
t-shirt says something about him he has
to buy you well that's not that's all
I've got
necie not Michael you can also subscribe
to the channel if you don't feel like
going for a drink with either of us see
you in the next video
you